back in 2020 we gave you a list of the
biggest game installs of all time and
thanks to your wonderful comments we're
back with 10 more thick games to haunt
your hard drive thick with three cs so
if you like big games and you cannot lie
make sure you hit that thumbs up button
[Music]
with a map 50 larger than horizon 4's
united kingdom forza horizon 5's mexico
was bound to take a heavy toll on player
hard drives the map is incredibly
detailed and diverse featuring multiple
biomes and giant dust storms not to
mention the inclusion of over 550 cars
tons of races activities stunts and more
and this is all before any major
expansions are released so imagine how
big the game is going to get going
forward also not to brag but i might
actually 100 this one i'm getting pretty
close
[Applause]
another racing game with a hefty
download is dirt rally 2.0 the game is
the second entry in dirt's rally and
rallycross focus spinoff to the main
dirt franchise it features tracks in
places like the us argentina spain new
zealand australia and poland similar to
dirt rally and dirt 4 dirt rally 2.0 is
an official game of the fia world
rallycross championship featuring
official cars and tracks from the world
rx calendar dlc for the game adds on a
ton of new cars of course as well as new
locations like finland greece germany
and more
in recent years assassin's creed games
just keep getting longer main quest
lines and even bigger worlds and in most
cases a game with a big open world
equals a big file size to hold all that
grass rocks and water odyssey the
follow-up to assassin's creed origins
features a map that is 62.5 percent
bigger than that of origins post-release
content includes the lost tales of
greece as well as the much larger legacy
of the first blade and the fate of
atlantis
this is krieg
say hello krieg
there are over 1 billion possible guns
in borderlands 3
1 billion guns and where do those assets
live on your hard drive of course
borderlands 3 takes place seven years
after the events of borderlands 2 and
involves a story where the player is
recruited by the crimson raiders to
battle a social media obsessed pair of
super twins similar to entries before it
borderlands 3 takes place on pandora
however that's not the only place you'll
explore as quest will take you to
sanctuary 3 prometheus athena's and more
the borderline series also loves dlc and
part 3 is no different the game received
four major pieces of campaign dlc packs
with new missions challenges and
gigabytes for your hard drive to hold
[Music]
25 years after our world was ripped
apart from the inside
we had peace years 4 takes place 25
years after the events of gears 3 and
follows marxist's son jd phoenix as he
and his friends take on a new threat to
the human race now back in my day you
could go on a locus killing adventure
with marcus and the gang without nearly
maxing out your hard drive but when it
comes to gears 4 and it's xbox one x
enhanced edition well that's a different
story because if you didn't know 4k
texture packs are no joke they're big
and pretty
kind of like a new york city skyscraper
you intrigue me wolf kissed
orphan and sibling
warrior and poet
you are many in one it seems
valhalla is a long ass game straight up
i'd even go as far as calling it the
definition of bloated but good god do i
love it so much and that's why it's
massive file size is continuing to take
up precious real estate on my
playstation 5's ssd i just never know
when i want to jump head first back into
that world similar to odyssey ac
valhalla is huge impact with all sorts
of things to do as well as a handful of
media expansions that make the game even
heavier and that post release content
isn't even done yet at the time of this
recording we're weeks away from the
release of dawn of ragnarok on march
10th
we don't want to kill any of you
but trust me
we will
wake him up a little released in 2018
red dead redemption 2 follows outlaw
arthur morgan as he attempts to deal
with rival gangs the government and the
decline of the wild west he's grown to
know so well despite having two in its
title the game is actually a prequel to
2010's red dead redemption and features
a bigger online multiplayer mode
appropriately titled red dead online
unfortunately rdo has been forced to
live in the shadow of its brother gta
online which has received way more
support post-launch
at this point in a post-war zone world
the call of duty franchise has become
known for being a hefty download size
with bulky updates however call of duty
vanguard breaks that trend with a
smaller size than its older brothers
however however things get a little
confusing when you factor in warzone the
free to play battle royale isn't
required to play vanguard but if you're
just jumping in for the first time with
this release and planning to play the
new pacific themed map then warzone can
bump up your overall file size for me
warzone lives with my huge install of
modern warfare a game that led our
previous list
dcs world aka digital combat simulator
world is a free-to-play digital
battlefield game that aims to provide an
authentic and realistic simulation of
military tanks ships and aircrafts it
features highly detailed maps with
millions of buildings 156 weapon systems
105 ground vehicles and more it's
basically like the deadly distant cousin
to microsoft flight simulator a 123 gig
game that made it onto our first list
[Music]
following two years of being in early
access ark survival evolved released on
august 29 2017 it's an action-adventure
survival game that actor vin diesel is a
huge fan of in fact mr diesel even
managed to squeeze himself into the lead
role of the game's sequel arc 2 which is
currently in development survival
evolved received its first paid
expansion in 2016 while still in early
access a move that upset plenty of
players and resulted in a storm of
negative steam reviews this dlc was
called scorched earth and featured an
all-new desert map in 2017 arc received
its second dlc titled abrasion which
brought a new underground slash alien
themed map to the game from there ark
would receive three more expansions in
the form of extinction and genesis part
one and two all of these make for a file
size as big as one of vin diesel's
biceps okay i'm done i'm done with the
lame jokes for now i promise so hit the
comment section and let us know if
there's any game we missed on this list
and hit the like button if you want to
see a part 3 in the future by then there
might be a call of duty with a one
terabyte install size you never know
[Music]
you